Good morning John
I am going to read to you my letter to 15 year old you
And yes I did just hold up my bank statement acting like it was a letter
It's not, it's a bank statement.
Actually it's an important update regarding
my overdraft coverage.
But before I read to you my important update regarding my overdraft coverage
I wanted to tell you a quick story
Okay, last week I thought I had a super clever thought
I was reading Vlogbrother's comments and someone made a reference to nerds dying virgins
which is not an uncommon statement among the troll population
And I just wanted to respond and say actually, I would argue that most nerds die..
And I didn't know what word to use there
At first I thought 'deflowered', most nerds die 'deflowered'
And while I think that may be technically true, depending on your perspective
It's kind of a.. the word has a negative connotation
Like, synonyms for 'deflowered' include like, 'corrupt' and 'sully' and 'dirtify'
Probably just dirty, dirty is a verb, as well as an adjective
And so I was thinking to myself, there is really no word for the opposite of virgin
And then I thought to myself, there should be a word for that!
There should be a word for when there isn't a word for something
And I love self-referential stuff like that
so I thought it was super clever
so I tweeted a question to the world
What's the word for when there should be a word for something but there isn't?
And I did not think I was asking a serious question
I'd just thought I was making a funny statement
But then, because Nerdfighters are Nerdfighters and Nerdfighters know this stuff
Two very quick tweets came in from rlunny and heatherklus
informing me that there is in fact a phrase for that, not quite a word
But it's called a 'lexical gap'
And there are a lot of lexical gaps in lots of different languages
for example in Romanian there's no word for shallow
So when you're translating into Romanian, you have to call it "not-so-deep"
English also has interesting lexical gaps
like the fact that we have no plural for the word "you"
which is a big one and it results in us having to invent words like "y'all" and "youse guys"
and so I very excitedly @ replied both of those people.
Though slightly disappointed that it was not a full word, THEN
Victoria tweeted saying a lexical gap or a lacuna, and I was like "a lacuna?!"
and so I looked up lacuna and lacuna means a lot of things
but if you're a linguist, a lacuna is when there is no word for something that there should be a word for
so yes there should be a word for when there should be a word for something
and there is a word for when there should be a word for something, and that word is lacuna
but if you're not talking to a linguist and you want to be more specific
you should probably use the phrase "lexical gap"
that is the end of my story and now I am going to read to you
My letter to 15-year-old John
So John, you're 15.
and like most 15 year olds, you feel like when you're forced in school to do math and science and
laboratory experiments, you're sort of being tortured.
But here's what science does for us, 15-year-old John
it helps us understand what to think about, and it gives us a framework for how to think about those things
Funny this is, 15-year-old John, when you're 33, you're going to write a video letter
to 15-year-old me saying those exact same things
about critical reading.
And guess what? You'll be right!
Because 15 and 33-year-old John, there are lots of ways
to arrive at a place where you can choose what to think about
and you know how to think about those things well
For you, it was reading complicated books critically
for me, it's statistics, and population dynamics, and evolutionary theory
But the truth of the matter is, to live a good life as a good person
it doesn't matter how you got there
It just matters that you do
Also, dump your girlfriend
I don't know who your girlfriend is, I don't know how much like her
but dump her right now, because John,
in the future, you are going to feel much much better about yourself
if there is ONE girlfriend in your past that you managed to dump
before she dumped you
Good luck with that 15-year-old John!
33-year-old John, I will see you on Friday